we had a great fun in the last Congress
talked about how bad Obamacare is and
I'm excited that today the Congress the
US House representative voted to repeal
it any manifestation of approval or
disapproval of proceedings is in
violation of the rules of the house the
bill was shoved down the throat of me
the House of Representatives and the
American people the amendment is adopted
the bill is passed and the amendment is
adopted motion reconsider is laid upon
the table
those opposed no our budget is not a
political document the bill is passed
repeal mandatory funding for
school-based health center construction
limit the federal government's
unprecedented power
the bill is passed on this vote the yeas
are 422 the nays are zero the bill is
passed health care is no longer
shortchanged the bill is passed the
conference report is adopted the bill is
passed the concurrent resolution is
agreed to mr. speaker today I rise in
opposition the nays are 199 tax on
medical devices the house rejects
Obamacare the motion is adopted the
concurrent resolution is agreed to the
patient's write repeal the motion is not
adopted the resolution is adopted the
bill is passed
again taking steps to dismantle the
president's health care law defund
Obamacare those opposed will say no the
motion is adopted the bill is passed the
bill is passed the bill is passed those
in favor say aye
repeals the current flawed formula for
reimbursing our doctors on this vote the
eyes are 406 the nays are 1 we haven't
even seen the worst of it yet the bill
is passed and without objection the
motion to reconsider is laid on the
table